who gives a crap about getting a 9-0
decision okay justice roberts
was successful in curtailing this
decision down to its narrowest possible
scope
and this is what he does he makes
excuses to uphold government power
and that's why i'm kind of fighting mad
over this particular decision okay so
the case which we have discussed briefly
on the show before
this is a case in which there is an
anti-so-called anti-discrimination law
in philadelphia and that
anti-discrimination law basically says
that no contractor with the city
government of philadelphia
is allowed to discriminate on the basis
of sexual orientation right that is what
the
law says okay and this comes into
conflict
pretty clearly with catholic adoption
and foster agencies
so catholic adoption and foster agencies
you're
a 16 year old catholic girl you get
pregnant you have a baby out of wedlock
you want to give it up for adoption or
you want to put it into foster care but
you want
the family that adopts to have the same
principles that you hold religiously
and so you want that baby to be fostered
by
a male female married couple which until
like literally the last five minutes
pretty much was considered the norm in
american life
and pretty much throughout the world
right was that a baby needs a mother and
a father this was considered an
extremely uncontroversial statement for
nearly all of human history was that a
baby needed
a mother and a father okay now it is
considered discriminatory if you say
that a baby needs
a mother and a father or that a mother
father married couples should be
preferred to any other form of family
formation whether you're talking about
two men
two women two brothers uh two sisters
a single woman a single man or any other
form
of family that if all other things being
equal
right and that's always the key all
other factors being held equal you
prefer a male female couple because a
child needs a mother and father
okay so catholic adoption agencies and
foster agencies
still hold by this this led the city of
philadelphia
to basically suggest that they would no
longer do work
with catholic foster agencies in fact
catholic foster agencies would not be
allowed to
warp because they have to work with
child protective services and the city
they would no longer be allowed to
operate in the city limits basically of
philadelphia
because they preferred male female
couples male male or female female or
single female or single male couple
families so this was elevated to the
supreme court
on religious freedom grounds right the
idea being
that this is a basic violation of
religious freedom which it very very
clearly is
the court ruled mind nothing in favor of
the catholic adoption agency and foster
agency so why am i pissed off the reason
i'm pissed off is the grounds of the
decision
because as always with the robbers court
he prefers unanimity
and narrowness over a divided court with
a broad ruling
and that's a serious problem for future
precedent
so here is how cnbc reports this
the supreme court on thursday delivered
a unanimous defeat to lgbt couples
in a high profile case over whether
philadelphia could refuse to contract
with a roman catholic adoption agency
that says its religious beliefs
prevented from working with same-sex
foster parents
chief justice john roberts wrote in an
opinion for a majority of the court that
philadelphia violated the first
amendment by refusing to contract with
catholic social services once it learned
the organization would not certified
same-sex couples for adoption roberts
wrote the free exercise clause of the
first amendment applicable to states
under the 14th amendment
provides congress shall make no law
prohibiting the free exercise of
religion as an initial matter it is
plain that the city's actions have
burdened
css religious exercise by putting it to
the choice of curtailing its mission or
approving
relationships inconsistent with its
beliefs
so the question in this case is whether
the supreme court was going to overrule
a another supreme court decision
that was called employment division
versus smith is a very famous supreme
court decision in which actually justice
scalia wrote the decision and he set a
standard for
when a law conflicts with religious
freedom how we rule i believe
in that case if i'm not mistaken i
believe the case was that there was a
drug law and it came into conflict
with a native american religious group
that used peyote
as some sort of of hallucinogen in their
religious practice
and what he said is a law of neutral
applicability
that affects religious people
differently is not in fact a violation
of freedom of religion
now the problem with that basic concept
and conservatives have been sort of up
in arms with employment
division versus smith ever since since
was that this actually treats freedom of
religion differently than any other
freedom in the american constitution
because the reality is that every other
freedom in the american constitution we
don't say that if there's a law of
neutral applicability and it just
happens to infringe
on your freedom in this particular area
well you know so be it so for example
if we said that there's an
anti-discrimination law and this
anti-discrimination law
prohibits discrimination in any field of
endeavor
it also happens to infringe on your
ability
to say a thing right it infringes on
your ability
to to speak freely we would have to have
a pretty serious first amendment
discussion as to what level of
anti-discrimination law is applicable
there
right this holds true let's say that
there was a law that just
was was intended on cracking down on
on the ability to disseminate
particular types of printed material and
a crackdown on free press
okay we would make sure there was a
pretty big carve out there for freedom
of the press
but when it comes to freedom of religion
we're going to treat that just as as
though there's no extra stake
for the us government in preserving
freedom of religion as opposed to
anything else in american life
that obviously is not true okay there
there's like employment division versus
smith has been a very controversial case
for a very long time and the standard
scalia sets there
is not one that really comports with the
original meaning of the constitution
and i rarely say that about schoolia but
i really think that's true in employment
division versus smith
justice thomas tends to feel the same
way so
here is the problem with this particular
decision it does not take on
employment division versus smith instead
what it did is decide this case on
extremely
narrow grounds so roberts
said that the city's nondiscrimination
policy was not generally applicable
instead of him saying
generally applicable non-discrimination
policies still have to make carveouts
for religion instead of him saying that
which would be understandable
and would have been much more protective
of religious freedom instead what robert
said
is he sort of gamed it he said well you
know this particular policy
is not a in a neutral policy
this one is so if they made it in
neutral policy maybe they could crack
down on religion but since it's not
really a neutral policy they can't crack
down on religion they did the exact same
thing justice roberts did the exact
same thing in the jack phillips
masterpiece cake shop
case and people on the right were sure
oh it's great and i was very critical of
that decision because i said here is the
problem
in that case very similar case there's
an anti-discrimination law in the state
of colorado it was brought against jack
phillips who again is now being
subjected
to actual discrimination in the state of
colorado on the basis of religion day in
and day out
in that particular case the master peace
cake shop case
jack phillips was told by a gay couple
that they they wanted him
to bake a cake for their gay wedding and
he said listen i'm happy to
sell you a cake i'm happy to provide you
a cake just as gay people but i'm not
going to participate in a gay wedding
because i'm a religious christian
and they sued and the supreme court
instead of saying
he has a religious right to practice his
religion
instead of them saying that very clearly
instead what they said is well the way
that the colorado human rights
commission adjudicated the case
demonstrated that they had animus for
him but if they didn't demonstrate the
anonymous for him
then maybe they could have forced him to
make the cake okay which again
does not protect religious rights and
it's the same thing here
okay justice roberts was successful in
curtailing this decision
down to its narrowest possible scope so
that he could get
kagan and sotomayor and briar on board
who gives a crap about getting a 9-0
decision
anybody who is concerned with
constitutional principle should be far
less concerned with getting a 9-0
decision
that quote-unquote upholds the integrity
of the court than they should be
with preserving religious freedom rights
under the first amendment to the
constitution
and that's why i'm kind of fighting mad
over this particular decision
robert said no matter the level of
deference we extend to the city the
inclusion of a formal system of entirely
discretionary exceptions
in its foster care standards renders the
contractual non-discrimination
requirement
not generally applicable so again he's
just making excuses
and this is what he does he makes
excuses to uphold government power
and when he strikes down government
power he does on very narrow grounds
that basically still upholds
governmental power he's a bad chief
justice
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang